bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant une audition de la
mission commune d'information sur le
rôle de l'union européenne dans la
gouvernance mondiale de l'internet alors
les sénateurs interroge aujourd'hui
fadi chehade qui est le président de
l'icann l'internet corporation for
assigned names and numbers les affaires
récentes liées aux activités de la nasa
la national security agency en france
ont démontré l'importance de la maîtrise
des données et la nécessité de peser
dans cette nouvelle gouvernance mondiale
de l'internet
mais le sable ravis de pouvoir vous
entendre dans la mesure où vous le savez
peut-être le sénat a enfin vous le savez
certainement puisque vous êtes là le cdh
a engagé une réflexion sur la
gouvernance d'internet et donc entendre
le président de l'icann est évidemment
pour nous une opportunité que nous ne
pouvions pas laisser passer je remercie
celles et ceux qui ont contribué à ce
rendez vous dans sébastien bachollet
david martinon qui nous ont permis
d'établir ce contact
je suis les élus petit nombre de
sénateurs qui seront face ray vous mais
vous savez cette aussi rare de voir des
sénateurs au sénat le vendredi que le
président de l'icann à paris donc il
faut que vous acceptiez 7 cette
situation vous avez occupé de très
nombreuses fonctions vous avez fondé et
dirigé de nombreuses entreprises du net
vous êtes si maîtrisé le très nombreuses
langues dont vous êtes un homme qui bien
que travaillant dans une société pour
une président une société de droit
américain a une vocation internationale
vous l'aurez compris c'est tout
cette difficulté qui nous faut examiner
ensemble c'est pas naturellement le seul
sujet mais la préoccupation qui est la
nôtre comme d'ailleurs celle de la
plupart des gouvernements et les
parlements européen et au delà
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui est de savoir
comment la régulation du net va évoluer
à partir de la création de l'icann
dans les années 90 comment les choses
vont désormais se passer pour assurer
peut être une influence est une
représentation plus large de l'ensemble
des parties prenantes tout en respectant
sa spécificité c'est une des difficultés
bien évidemment auxquels nous sommes
confrontés donc pour nous c'est
important de vous écouter
donc peut-être vais-je voulait c'est
d'abord la parole pour nous présenter à
la fois l'association que vous dirigez
pour nous dire ensuite quelles sont les
préoccupations dominantes et puis après
nous pourrons venir peut-être plus
directement des questions plus précises
merci beaucoup merci de m'avoir invité
je suis content d'être ici vous allez
excusez mon français est un peu limité
quand même j'ai j'ai appris le français
à beyrouth quand j'étais jeune de là bas
et j'ai quitté le liban il ya plus que
trente ans donc je n'ai pas beaucoup
utilisé mon français
mais j'apprécie le fait qu'on peut au
moins communiqué parler ensemble
aujourd'hui écoutés l'icann existe
depuis 15 ans c'est une c'est une
organisation
quand je suis arrivé beaucoup américaine
qui avait des racines dans dans l'état
américain et puis qui est devenue une
société californienne indépendante
privée et qui vraiment serre au monde un
rôle très unique et très important
l'internet n'est pas un réseau c'est des
dizaines de milliers de réseau ce qui
rend l'internet unis c'est le fait
qu'ils art3 type 2
ce qu'on appelle d'identifiants qui font
que la base technique de l'internet et
unis alors c'est des petites racines il
ya 3 3 racines à l'internet une pour les
non donc aujourd'hui on a fêté points
paris par exemple c'était une très belle
fête
j'ai vu ce le maire ce matin on a parlé
de l'innovation que paris va bâtir sur
points paris c'est merveilleux
merveilleux
les noms les nombres donc chaque chaque
scène téléphone ou même ordinateur qui
parle à l'internet a besoin de nombreux
unique et tous ces nombres sont
distribués au monde à travers l'icann et
c'est important que c'est non pour soi
unique
alors c'est pour ça qu'ils sont dans un
dans une racine et puis il ya des
paramètres techniques pour l'internet il
ya trois choses et icahn s'occupe de ça
maintenant on l'a fait depuis 15 ans il
faut bien dire que ça a été un travail
très bien fait parce que depuis 15 ans
pas pour une seconde le système a été
sous pression ou nantes avait là était
en place et toujours rhône pour 15 ans
c'est très important c'est la sécurité
et la stabilité de l'internet là et le
système est désigné d'une façon
distribué comme ça il est très stable
depuis 15 ans il est très stable
maintenant il ya la question dont je
suis sûre on va en parler du rôle
particulier que les états unis a
toujours dans les cannes et on peut en
parler plus tard mais je crois que le
moment
comme j'ai bien dit à new delhi
récemment le moment est arrivé comme
l'icann est mûr est prête pour que le
rôle des états unis avancent vers un
rôle mondial et que le bâton est passé à
la communauté mondiale pour garder là
finances du monde que l'icann fait son
travail comme on l'a fait pour quinze
ans sans interruption
l'icann est ouverte à tous il faut être
très clair
les caennais totalement transparent tout
ce qu'on fait et transparent sur l'étal
tous nos réunions sont ouvertes
n'importe qui peut venir personne ne
nous paie de l'argent pour participer à
faire ce qu'on fait c'est totalement
gratis totalement ouvert dans tout le
monde
l'onu précise présent tout en les
langues de l'onu
nous on fait ça et on ajoute le
portugais et on va ajouter d'autres
langues prochainement donc on est ouvert
on est international
tout le monde est inclus sûrement que
comme on a commencé aux états unis et
même dans le monde
ouest on a une base waston comme les
chinois m'ont dit la semaine dernière à
beijing
on va changer ça moi j'ai déjà cassé les
aides comme tous deux week-ends en trois
il y aura un raid courte à los angeles
on a déjà ouvert leur aide pour istanbul
et 1 à singapour et moi même avec ma
famille je veux vivre à singapour début
le mois prochain pour quelques mois et
puis je m'installe à istanbul pour
montrer que le président de l'as cannes
peut faire tout son travail à travers le
monde et j'avais un staff de 120
personnes et un budget de 90 millions $
l'an dernier
mais non nous avons plus que 300
personnes partout dans le monde j'ai
ouvert des bureaux à montevideo à
beijing à
à genève la semaine dernière donc
partout dans le monde
donc les can change la posture délicate
doit changer on doit être dedans prêt à
être une organisation pour le monde et
c'est pour ça je crois que le board main
mais parce que j'amène cette vision
cette vision que on peut pas être une
organisation qui sert le monde avec un
corps américain pas parce que le coeur
america ne va pas le quart américain a
sauvegardé l'internet pour beaucoup
d'années mais l'internet est devenu
maintenant centrales au monde et ça doit
être un outil du monde donc sa
gouvernance doit être pour le monde et
c'est ce que je suis en train de faire
merci de ses propos liminaires je n'ai
pas présenté avec tellement de régates
au lin qui représente pas morin de seuil
et notre rapporteur qui a
malheureusement pas pu se joindre à nous
cet après midi mais qui est membre de la
mission
j'entends bien ce que vous nous dites je
crois qu'il ya une volonté réelle
effectivement de faire évoluer les
choses et ce qui est possible d'aller un
tout petit peu plus loin dans la
réflexion qui est que la vôtre et celle
qui est
la réflexion de l'icann dans ce domaine
l'union européenne a déjà à plusieurs
reprises fait savoir son souhait de voir
ces évolutions se concrétiser au-delà de
ces réorganisation géographique dont
nous avait parlé est ce que d'autres
pistes sont envisageables
seconde question auquel j'aurais
tendance à sur laquelle j'aurais
tendance à vous interroger
elle concerne cette fois la manière dont
justement les rapports entre une europe
et d et l'ail kahn peuvent se faire mais
plus globalement la façon union
européenne a réagi est ce qui s'est
passé récemment sur à travers les
révélations sur la nsa et snowdon avec
la volonté extrait par la merkel de
travailler à l'internet européen
qu'est-ce que vous inspire cette
proposition de la chancelière allemande
est ce que vous pensez possible de faire
à la fois vivre un système universel qui
souhaitent également un système qui est
des caractéristiques et les sécurité
régionale pour des raisons qui sont
liées aux aux événements que j'ai cité
de la même façon nous avons reçues pour
dans nos différentes auditions
l'inde est l'un de ceux qui a contribué
à la création d'internet qui est louis
pouzin qui nous a parlé de la volonté de
travailler sur des racines libre des
racines ouverte sa volonté qui est la
sienne de mettre en place quelque chose
qui soit encore plus plus ouverts
aujourd hui clary kahn tout en estimant
que ça ne m'était pas en danger
l'universalité du système j'aimerais
connaître votre votre sentiment voilà
ces trois grands chantiers mais je
serais heureux de connaître votre
sentiment sur ces trois points sur le
premier point c'est important que je
sois clair que la globalisation de tout
ce qui est opérationnel c'est un premier
temps mais c'est passé il faut faire
plus j'ai présenté au conseil
d'administration de l'icann
il ya quelques jours un plan qui va
beaucoup plus loin que ça et je suis
content de vous dire que j'arrive un
jour un peu historique pour les can
parce que hier le porte a mis une
résolution très clair le conseil
d'administration de l'icann
en me donnant leu leu leu greenlight
d'avancé sur ces cinq initiative très
importante
la première c'est de commencer le
travail vers la création d'une structure
parallèle légales internationales
peut-être en suisse pour les cas ça
c'est nouveau c'est la première fois
deuxièmement nous donner la possibilité
avec eux de travailler sur un plan pour
globaliser les fonctions ian a qui sont
les fonctions coeur de notre travail sur
les identifiants de l'internet
donc ça ça veut dire regardez sur le
rôle des états unis et voir comment le
oversight rôle des états unis peut être
remplacé par un rôle mondial très
important
jamais avant ça a été annoncé par notre
conseil que je commence à travailler sur
ces choses
troisièmement ça c'est ça c'est très
important nous avons à nous avons un
instrument légal qui s'appelle
affirmation of commitments c'est
l'affirmation de nos responsabilités au
monde de faire ce qu'on doit faire avec
la confidence que le monde mais en nous
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que ce
document est signé par nous paris cannes
et par le gouvernement américain
donc j'ai pris le ok de notre conseil
d'administration
pour la première fois aussi de changer
ce contrat de tounens contre-preuve de
prendre ce contrat au niveau
international et que le contrat soit
signé par le monde pas par un
gouvernement du monde
quatrièmement
que on commence à étudier nos structures
de
de police e-mailing et de les avancer
comme ça ces structures prennent une 10
on note beaucoup plus internationale est
beaucoup plus ouvert et surtout le gac
qui est le gardien de zurich métier de
l'icann de penser comment le gac va
avancer et se se réformer ça c'est aussi
la première fois que le board parle
directement de ces choses là et
finalement la cinquième chose c'est de
travailler sur le routeur système la
racine des non et comment avancer le
mode de travail sur les racines pour
qu'il soit il ya quelques petits détails
dans la résolution mais je vous passe 1
par exemple le rôle des pays la
souveraineté des pays sur les
changements de leurs informations sur la
racine
par exemple vous avez en france point fr
quand point fr veut changer un
administrateur ou des détails
ils doivent passer par l'icann c'est bon
mais est-ce que l'icann peut changer
quelque chose sur point fr sans que
point fr accède à ça aujourd'hui
oui moi j'ai proposé que dans le futur
on ne pourra pas faire ça que c'est le
contrôle du pays de leurs racines de la
partie de la racine qui sait des choses
comme je suis nouveau dans ce monde que
je vois totalement claire pays comme la
france un pays comme comme n'importe
quel pays la chine doit avoir contrôle
sur le can tricot de le code de leur
pays donc ça c'est les 5 initiative ça a
été annoncé hier donc c'est tout nouveau
je suis vraiment content que notre
conseil d'administration qui est
représentée ici par deux français sur
une ou lanvin et monsieur sébastien
bachollet et qui d'ailleurs la france a
une représentation la plus haute de
n'importe quel pays
by capita dans le conseil
d'administration de l'icann de
représentant de la france et c'est
vraiment ça démontre le rôle important
que la france joue et on avait un autre
aussi bertrand de lachapelle qui était
aussi dans le conseil un autre français
qui m'a aidé et qui continue à m'aider
beaucoup à mettre en place ces
changements énormes qu'on voit donc oui
il ya plus que le changement
opérationnel
votre deuxième question très importante
ça c'est à propos d'eux d'où l'idée de
l'allemagne et de créer un internet
européen ou un internet allemands ils
ont dit tout d'abord puis ils ont changé
d'avis dans choses pas claires où elle
est maintenant mais je vais voir des
responsables allemands dans quelques
jours et on en parlera regardez la
fragmentation de l'internet est très
dangereux et très dangereuse
même les chinois qui ont une masse
énorme
ils ont 620 millions d'utilisateurs ne
veulent pas voir un internet fragmenté
parce que beaucoup de leurs applications
aujourd'hui ont des centaines de
millions d'utilisateurs en dehors de la
chine
personne ne veut voir la base de
l'internet fragmenté
si elle se fragmente on aura des
problèmes maintenant en dessus de la
base est-ce qu'on veut proposer des
solutions des api
la scion des des propositions globales
régional et national
certainement pourquoi pas c'est
important d'innovations doit se passer
partout
aujourd'hui j'étais à paris au sentier
numa et j'étais impressionnée par
l'énergie les idées tout ce qui se passe
c'est merveilleux s'il crée des idées
pour le monde ou créent des idées pour
paris ou créent des idées pour la france
ou pour l'europe c'est ce qu'il faut
faire c'est l'internet c'est l'internet
c'est comme ça qu'il faut se passer
mais si on commence à créer d une police
des politiques qui fragmentent le coeur
de l'internet comme une base pour
l'économie du monde pour la connexion
humaine de tous les gens je crois qu'on
va perdre quelque chose de très valable
et d'ailleurs on vient de finir une
étude avec le boston consulting group
qui est très importante
une étude qui est sorti je vous laisse
l'étude qui est qui parle des frictions
sur l'internet c'est-à-dire si chaque
pays commence à créer des frictions
ils ont étudié 55 frictions je vais
envoyer ça à madame merkel l faut
qu'elle le lise parce que l'allemagne
ont ils ont montré les frictions que
l'allemagne allait frictions que la
france a et c
si les pays ajoute à ces frictions au
niveau de l'infrastructure au niveau des
industries honni de haut niveau des
individuels au niveau du contenu le plus
de frictions le le plus l'économie sera
affecté d'ailleurs ils ont démontré que
entre le suède qui venu en top et niji
ac est venu au fond sur sur le nu index
du dcg il ya une différence de 2.5 de
diddy ciment ça et c'est tout à cause de
la friction est ce qu'on veut vraiment a
ajouté de la friction
mais non finalement je voudrais c'est
quelque chose qui est
un élément très important pour moi on
peut pas créer un système global qui ne
respectent pas le système national et
beaucoup de gens de l'internet parfois
pense que l'internet globale prend
précédente ce qui est national
c'est impossible moi à mon avis il faut
respecter nationale il faut respecter le
régional il faut le concept de sa psy d
allaiter qui respecte que si quelque
chose est importante à un niveau plus
bas
elle passe tout d'abord donc le global
n'enlève pas le national il le respecte
il faut trouver un moyen de trouver des
relations entre les deux de la
synchronisation entre les deux pas que 1
enlève l'autre ça c'est très important
aussi
vous aviez une troisième question même à
les compléter cette deuxième question si
effectivement cette idée de l'internet
européen a été évoquée et c'est vrai
qu'elle mériterait d'être précisée parce
que je ne pense pas qu'il s'agit dans
l'esprit de madame merkel de vouloir
casser et bloqué un système qui
aujourd'hui à ce caractère à la fois
transatlantique et internationale
c'est parce que des questions ont été
très vite soulever pour la sécurité des
communications des personnes privées
comme des officiels que tout cela
évidemment a déclenché une perte de
confiance considérable quand on sait par
exemple que même en développant un club
européen
si c'est claude censure du matériel
gérés par les sociétés américaines de
droit américain le gouvernement
américain resterait en situation de
pouvoir exiger ces informations avec en
plus un codicille de la loi américaine
qui dit qu'elles ne doivent pas le
révéler aux autorités concernées ça peut
expliquer bien évidemment qui un souci
des gouvernements européens comme
d'autres je sais que vous allez être une
des chevilles ouvrières de la conférence
qui va se tenir à sao-paulo syllabes
rousseff a souhaité soulevé ce problème
c'est notamment pour cette raison
donc comment est ce que je sais que vous
avez forcément ces sujets renommée qui
n'est pas un homme politique mais
d'abord un deuil du technicien
et comment peut-on rétablir cette
confiance sinon est-ce qu'on ne risque
pas de déboucher sur un processus tels
que vous décrivez est pour des raisons
qu'il soit et c'est naturel de la part
des états des citoyens qui veulent se
protéger
alors vous savez très bien que du point
de vue à cannes on n'est pas dans le
domaine des contenus
donc on est un niveau plus bas il faut
être clair que même dans notre niveau il
ya des données par exemple quand on
enregistre un site il ya des données et
d'ailleurs les données ne sont pas chez
l'icann ils sont chez les régistres à
ski qui vendent le nom mais on a eu un
contrat avec ces chaleurs et qu'est ce
qu'ils font avec les noms et dans le cas
de l'europe par exemple c'était clair
que quelques-unes des des demandes dans
nos contrats n'étaient pas alignés avec
des lois européennes et tout de suite on
a mis dans le contrat que si ce qui est
dans le contrat n'est pas aligné avec
avec la loi de votre pays
monsieur le registre à vous pouvez venir
chez nous et on peut enlever cette
demande et ça se passe déjà par exemple
pour des questions de données en france
et on vient de d'annoncer qu'un grand
registre art français on va enlever
quelques demandes dans notre contrat
parce que c'est pas lié avec la loi
française
donc on est très sensible au fait qu' il
ya des lois nationales qui doivent être
acceptées pas seulement accepter mais on
aurait à travers notre travail
maintenant du point de vue votre
question sur qui et sur la peur de la
sécurité le fait que l'allemagne voit
que un moyen de changer le
le système actuel de services sur
l'internet c'est d'avoir des services
européens rarement je crois du point de
vue avoir des services allemands avoir
des services européens qui sont en
compétition avec d'autres services du
monde soit je crois qu'on est tous pour
une bonne compétition et c'est bien
c'est bien mais au niveau de la
structure technique où on est si ça ça
se fragmente on va perdre beaucoup des
possibilités qui nous donne les
bénéfices économiques qu'on a
aujourd'hui
mais au point de vue applications c
c'est le marché qui va décider aussi
peut-être quelques et avons décidé mais
ça je crois qu'on va laisser ça pour
pour pour les décisions des du marché et
des pays mais il faut pas commencer à
parler d'internet nationale je crois pas
que ça c'est une bonne idée
parler de la possibilité d'application
internationale partout d'autres offerte
qui sont peut-être plus aligné avec
d'autres systèmes ou d'autres ça c'est
bien je crois que ça c'est ça nous ça
nous va tous bien c'est bien pour
l'utilisateur c'est bien pour l'internet
mais j'ai très peur quand j'entendais
les le nom de pays ou de régions puis
internet c'est comme s'il y aura
plusieurs internet ça ce sera pierre
ce que c'était si vous serez sur les
racines ouvertes les propositions de
monsieur cousant la réflexion qui est
menée ce sujet et plusieurs racines de
l'internet qui a 13 racine aujourd'hui
où il ya une racine avec 13 opérateurs
dans le monde
comme j'ai bien dit 10 aux états unis
deux en europe et une au japon le
système de racine est très délicat parce
qu'il doit être
ils doivent rester indépendant est-ce
qu'on peut mettre plus de racines est ce
qu'on peut et changer d'opérateur de
racines ça c'est les questions qui sont
demandés tout le temps à cannes a par
exemple une des treize racines c'est la
racine elle parce qu'ils sont a donc
nous avons la racine
elle est notre racines et on a dix-sept
racines et répliquées partout dans le
monde
donc les racines les 13 même sont
répliquées partout dans le monde nous
avons des centaines de réplication dans
le monde
donc les systèmes de racine et bien
répliquer et partout dans le monde
la question c'est pas les 13 si les
treize doivent être 20 ou le au sens où
dix mille ou deux
la question c'est qui mais les
changements dans la racine
parce qu'il ya un système qui qui
informe les 13 qu'on va ajouter points
paris qu' on va ajouter le sud sudan
c'est parce que c'est un nouveau pays et
en moulage août
alors ce système c'est le système que le
monde est en train de regarder
maintenant
et aujourd'hui ce système est très clair
bien établie avec une haine dernière
étape dans ce système qui parle de
hockey du département de commerce
américain alors tout ou des étapes des
étapes et en fin de compte quand on est
prêt à ajouter point de paris ont décidé
de l'ajouter passe
on a passé toutes les étapes et la
dernière étape
c'est une demande au département de
commerce américain de faire un hockey et
ça ça fait partie de la réforme de
rayhana que le beau le conseil
d'administration m'a donné la
possibilité de deux d'en parler
maintenant et on croit que on est au
point où il sera important que le rôle
des américains
maintenant comme la dernière étape doit
être remplacé par un mécanisme global
international
mais le fait que la 13 racines ou deux
racines ou de sa racine qui ont déjà des
milliers de de réplication partout dans
le monde je crois que ce n'est plus
autant l'issue mondiale issue mondial et
qui a le droit de toucher cette racine
et là nous serons les administrateurs de
ça
l'important c'est qu'ils aient un
oversight mondial de ce qu'on fait ça
c'est l'important beaucoup si vous en
êtes d'accord je vais passer la parole à
mon collègue andré gattolin qui va vous
poser de nouvelles questions
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président merci encore d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
tout d'abord je voudrais revenir sur
deux points que vous avez évoquées dans
vos réponses
là tout récemment vous avez évoqué le
cas de l'accord nécessaire du
département du commerce américain pour
le changement d'une racine est ce qu'il
y a des cas nombreux peu nombreux ou il
s'est opposé à ce type de chose qu'un
deuxième point avant de venir des
questions plus générales
là aussi en référence à ce que vous avez
évoquées précédemment vous nous avez
parlé de cinq initiatives que vous avez
présenté au conseil d'administration de
l'icann et notamment le premier point
que vous avez évoqué très rapidement
vous avez dit évoluer vers la création
d'une structure parallèle à l'icann en
suisse alors je voudrais avoir un tout
petit peu plus de précisions
si c'est dans votre logique globale de
mouvement vers une gouvernance on va
dire allez poste américaine vers une
gouvernance globale et dans quel schéma
précisément cet aspect da s'inscrit s'il
vous plaît merci merci alors sur le
deuxième question oui l'idée c'est que
on avance vers une structure légale qui
a qui est dans un cadre international
accepté légitime pour le monde aussi du
point de vue légal et le conseil m'a
donné la possibilité de commencer avec
eux à étudier le meilleur moyen de créer
cette structure parallèle dans le monde
et puis on verra quelle partie de ce
qu'on fait va être sous cette structure
et quelle partie ce qu'on fait peut-être
sous d'autres structures maintenant nous
avons des bureaux ac qui grandissent
vite en singapour à istanbul donc notre
structure légale va changer et genève et
genève et genève on a ouvert le bureau
la semaine dernière d'ailleurs et nous
avons déjà une structure là bas mais qui
n'est pas au point où elle doit être
c'est une structure enjoy mais non on
doit penser à une structure plus
international que ça et c'est ce que le
conseil d'administration m'a donné la
possibilité de discuter et et je crois
qu'on va avancer assez vite sur ça c'est
important pour le monde
votre première question était sur le le
rôle pardon oui lever tôt possible alors
as américain et est ce que ce veto c'est
a été utilisé 40 nombreuses fois dans
quels cas de circonstance alors en
quinze ans durant les quinze ans passés
pas une seule fois
ils ont exercé un nom point final
pas une seule fois donc c'est important
de savoir ça et pas une seule fois
ils nous ont demandé de faire quelque
chose qui n'a pas été décidé par la
communauté c'est à dire ya eu un moment
où quelqu'un a dit oh les américains
vous ont demandé d'enlever la syrie delà
de la racine quand la syrie n'était plus
sur l'internet
récemment s'est jamais passé ils n'ont
jamais en 15 ans demandé qu'on enlève
quelque chose vous savez très bien que
ça ce sera sérieux et qu'ils n'ont
jamais fait ça donc je crois que le rôle
américain n'était pas un rôle de
contrôle c'était un rôle pour donner la
confidence au monde que l'icann fait son
travail et de leur part ils attendaient
que l'icann devient mur est prête pour
passer cette confidence à sa communauté
c'est très important ce que c'est que il
attendait le moment est d'ailleurs dans
la dans la création de l'icann le
premier jour que l'icann est écrit c'est
écrit dans les papiers de création que
le gouvernement américain attendra le
moment juste ou l'icann est prête pour
passer le oversight rôle à la communauté
et moi depuis deux trois mois je suis
très clair public en public en disant
que les américains ont été de bons stolt
de bon oui accompagnateurs il faut
respecter ce qu'ils ont fait il faut
respecter que pour 15 ans ils ont fait
leur rôle mais il est moment pour tous
que ce rôle parce à la communauté
mondiale et mais c'est pas pour dire que
les les américains ont fait n'ont fait
que ce qui est juste il faut les
remercier même pour être maître pour ce
qu'ils ont fait ils ont fait un travail
très clair et très bien ils ont gardé la
stabilité de l'intérieur
mais il est temps qu'ils qu'ils font la
promesse qu'ils ont fait eux mêmes dès
la création délicat qu'il est mort il
est le moment de le faire pardonner
beaucoup d'intérêt mais vous nous disiez
qu'il n'y a pas eu de demandes des etats
unis en revanche il ya eu des saisies de
nom de des refus par dans les deux il ya
des saisies de noms de domaines qui ont
été décidées par le gouvernement
américain aurait par le département du
commerce quelle nature aussi à
introduire des petites tensions et des
inquiétudes
donc moi je partage évidemment votre
sentiment que on peut pas reprocher aux
états unis d'avoir su organiser dans les
années 90 autour du vice président al
gore et d'autres personnalités ce que
d'autres n'auraient pas fait est ce que
la france peut détruire ou l'europe
aurait pu faire à une époque et n'a pas
fait donc d'une certaine manière il
serait injuste de reprocher au
gouvernement américain de savoir prendre
en compte les dossiers stratégiques
comme cela en temps je me réjouis de
voir effectivement que les choses sont
ces petites d'évoluer dans le sens que
vous indiquez parce que justement cette
question de saisie de noms de domaine
était de nature à créer des difficultés
détention je ne sais pas d'ailleurs si
vous souhaitez vous exprimer là dessus
puisque ce sont des affaires qui sont
passées mais évidemment c'est de nature
à inquiéter puisque on voit bien tout de
même que ça peu sur le plan juridique
créé des situations extrêmement délicate
alors pour être clair les domaines qui
ont été saisis pas seulement parler le
gouvernement américain mais par beaucoup
de gouvernements
c'est des domaines de deuxième niveau
c'est à dire ils ne sont pas dans notre
racines dans la racine on a tout ce qui
est à droite du point
pas à gauche du point donc c'est pas
notre travail c'est à dire point de
paris on le met dans la racine
maintenant aujourd'hui dlc ou tour
eiffel annoncé qu'ils auront tour eiffel
préparer ça c'est pas dans la racine
ça c'est dans le registre y deux points
paris qui sera l'afnic
je crois maintenant laisse donc le
saisissement se passe quand un
gouvernement pour des décisions légales
décide que
il ya un domaine qui crée des problèmes
ça c'est entre le gouvernement et les
registre on n'est ni cannes n'est pas
dans dans et pour être direct sur ça il
ya des choses qui se passent parfois qui
sont pas aussi écrites ou dit parce que
c'est des choses très qui était
important pour la sécurité des pays et
l'icann quelquefois travail avec europol
interpol au fbi à et quand il ya des
problèmes légale dans des sites et on
est et c'est là qu'on fait quelque chose
mais dans un cadre légal et notre rôle
et est entièrement un rôle de
coordination parce que nous on a pas
laid on n'aura pas délaisser point de
paris ça sera celle enregistrée leur
industrie mais on participe avec les les
la sécurité les organes de sécurité
mondiaux et quelquefois nationaux quand
il ya quelque chose de qui est contre la
loi et qui qui doit être adressée très
vite on coordin avec eux ont fait une
coordination avec eux pour aider à
résoudre ces problèmes mais jamais la
racine
jamais la racine ça c'est une tarte à
chiba de ce point de vue je voulais vous
demander monsieur le président il est
parfois reproché à les canes qui est une
société à but non lucratif chargé de
mission qui sont dans le technique
d'avoir développé parfois peut-être
excessivement des activités de nature
commerciale par exemple vous proposer à
la location des adresses points 20 août
of fine qui alors d'un point de vue là
encore peut-être de ce côté ci de
l'atlantique met en danger les
indications géographiques protégées et
c'est si dans les négociations d'accord
transatlantique entre l'union européenne
et le canada est aujourd'hui entre
l'union européenne et des états unis
ce sont des questions assez sensible
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
critiques
plus précisément dont souffre une paire
m comment voyez-vous aboutir la
discussion qui est engagée sur les
nombreux domaines concernant l'évent le
forum oui absolument en particulier
toujours très sensible en france 11 mars
est ressorti de nouveau qu'est ce qui se
passe sur le deuxième niveau c'est pas
le travail de l'icann ce qui se passe
avant le point c'est pas le travail de
l'icann y les problèmes dont vous avez
parlé c'est des problèmes qui n'ont pas
été résolues dans beaucoup d'autres
domaines internationaux entre les
gouvernements et l'icann ne va pas les
résoudre c'est c'est ici depuis 10 ans
les gouvernements essaient de résoudre
ces problèmes dans d'autres cadres
émission ils n'ont pas arrivé à les
résoudre
je crois pas qu'on doit se mettre au
milieu et essayer de résoudre ces
problèmes on doit faire attention parce
que comme vous avez dit c'est sensible
mais c'est des cdd tout ce que j'ai pu
faire pour d'autres vins c'est d'inviter
et tous les
et les partis qui étaient en contention
et je leur ai donné mon bureau j'ai
facilité la possibilité qu'ils peuvent
sans parler j'espère qu'ils arriveront à
quelque chose mais en fin de compte
ali khan le le garde malade base rich
media a essayé de trouver une solution
ils n'ont pas pu trouver un consensus
entre tous les pays du monde sur ça donc
la solution a été poussé à mon niveau au
niveau de notre conseil d'administration
et je demandais permission du conseil
avant qu'on fasse une décision d'inviter
tous les les
les gens impliqués dans cette décision
pour voir s'ils peuvent arriver entre
eux parce que c'est pas notre rôle entre
donc on a créé l'espace pour un dialogue
et ça c'est quelque chose que l'icann
n'avait pas fait dans le passé c'était
quelque chose on disait c'est un
problème qui n'est pas le nôtre qu'ils
essaient mais je croise c'est notre rôle
comme quelqu'un qui s'occupe du bien
public d'essayer au moins de trouver un
mode de dialogue donc je suis en train
d'essayer pas seulement sur les issues
de points 20 il ya d'autres issues aussi
dès qu'elles ont travaillé j'ai j'ouvre
la possibilité de dialogue pour qu'on
trouve des solutions entre les lélés les
parties dans ce dans ce dans ce dialogue
ça veut dire s'il fut me permettre
d'être un tout petit peu plus précis
vous n'envisagez pas d'attribuer deux
noms de domaine mettons cause tel ou tel
type de vin sans l'accord de la filière
ou contre l'avis de la filière viticole
vous attendez que ses soucis mais
j'espère qu'ils arriveront à une
solution c'est pas moi de décider et je
vais je
on doit leur donner un espace pour en
parler pour arriver à quelque chose je
crois que ça c'est la chose juste pour
l'icann de faire mais de simplement
fraude bouquet dire voilà c'est le
procès vous avez vous avez vous avez mis
vos papiers donc tout et tout est fait
je crois que ce n'est pas une
responsabilité complète comprend on doit
essayer de trouver une solution mais
c'est pas à nous de décider
on va attendre et voir et j'espère que
ils vont trouver une solution entre
j'espère sa fin ça peut ça plus facile
pour nous tous oui sur une question qui
concerne les canes puisqu'on est dans
une question de gouvernance
internationale voire de gouvernance
mondiale qui dit gouvernance dit
toujours légitimité et représentativité
il se trouve que votre organisme
notamment pour préparer la grande
réunion sur la gouvernance d'internet
sympa au lot avait constitué un panneau
et ce qui est une chose très importante
mais la première question jeune homme
qui vient d'un autre milieu celui des
enquêtes d'opinion des sondages
préalablement à celui parlementaire sait
toujours comment sont désignés les gens
parce que vous évoquez très
régulièrement le terme de travailler
pour la communauté
mais comment actuellement au sein de
l'icann constitutes oms sur quelles
bases au delà de la compétence et de
l'intelligence techniques technologiques
l'habileté je pense diplôme annick
diplomatique demain mais comment
constitutant je dirais la
représentativité est aussi la légitimité
de ceux qui sont amenés à participer à
cette gouvernance
tout d'abord tout le monde est accepté
on commence par ça il ya beaucoup d
organismes aujourd'hui même les parties
de l'onu ou si j'arrive et je tape à la
porte pour rentrer participer
je ne serai pas inclus
l'icann tout le monde est inclus tout le
monde les gouvernements les sociétés
l'industrie société civile n'importe qui
arrive même pour pour le brésil comme
c'est on va faire avec madame rousseff
cette conférence dans l'esprit
d'ouverture
on va voir des dizaines de chambres dans
le monde dans le monde entier dans
peut-être on est en train d'essayer de
le mettre dans 100 pays où tout le monde
peut participer réellement en temps réel
avec nous par vidéo donc l'important
c'est de penser que la première
légitimation de du process vient de son
ouverture complète sa transparence
complète mais dans le problème que n'a
pour être direct c'est que si on va à
notre nos réunions la représentation est
toujours plus tôt ouah stunt l'europe et
les états unis et quelques autres pays
la réalité c'est que honnart le dernier
la dernière rencontre de l'icann il y
avait 140 pays représentés donc on a
beaucoup de représentations mais
relative speaking c'est encore pts dont
qu'il faut faire un effort plus grand et
c'est pour ça que j'ai mis beaucoup de
bureaux autour du monde pour engager des
communautés et les amener à l'icann leur
donner les facilités les traductions
l'instruction le on a commencé tout une
line learning plateforme pour aider les
gens à participer
pas seulement dans le niveau technique
mais aussi dans le niveau juridique
légal pour pour faire les choses
ensemble
donc la légitimité viendra de notre
ouverture de la participation complète
la représentation de tous ce matin j'ai
rencontré beaucoup d'entreprises
françaises pour medef pour les invités
aussi de participer quand on quand on
dit que les entreprises américaines ou
d'un certain pays où plus de deux
présences dans la gouvernance de
l'internet beaucoup de fois parce que
nos entreprises ils sont pas
donc il faut qu'ils arrivent iso c'est
tout vert la participation et des tout
ce qu'on fait à l'icann est traduit en
français on commence par ça tout tout
notre site tous nos travail tout ce
qu'on fait donc la possibilité de
légitimation et fait à travers ça et
puis dans l'icann qui a beaucoup de
groupes grouping pour lester co2 ya les
gouvernements on à 133 gouvernements
représentés à l'icann maintenant on
allait les la société civile on a les
utilisateurs on a les l'industrie avec
tous les types d'industries inclut les
et hop les deux les services providers
ils sont tous représentés tous nos
rencontres sont ouvertes
je dépense des millions de dollars à
chaque rencontre pour aider les gens qui
peuvent pas venir qui n'ont pas les
moyens
donc je joue on fait tout ce qu'il faut
pour être ouvert pour que la légitimité
de l'icann continue à être de notre
inclusive death and accountability and
accountability s'est pas seulement
d'inviter les gens c'est que les gens
quand ils viennent ils savent comment
nous mettons notre responsabilité de
faire les choses bien et de les faire
pour tous également en bonne forme
si on ne fait pas bien les gens ne
viendront plus d'ailleurs notre dernier
notre dernière un autre avait plus que
tu presque 3000 personnes de tout le
monde on fait ça trois fois par an donc
cessé ces deux là mais non le rôle des
gouvernements et la dernière le dernier
commentaire que je veux faire sur la
légitimité
le rôle des gouvernements à l'icann est
très important et on a vraiment une
chance incroyable d'avoir 133
gouvernement qui sont impliqués et
investit dans nick hamm et chaque 2 3
mois s'agrandit et je crois que
prochainement on sera au complet
pourquoi pourquoi ça c'est important
c'est si on n'a pas les gouvernements à
table on peut pas dire qu'on est
vraiment ouvert et qu'on représente tous
les systèmes du monde
les utilisateurs les industries la
société civile les académiques les tous
ensemble sans les gouvernements on
manque quelque chose d'important et
c'est pour ça que depuis le début
l'icann s'est investie invité les
gouvernements et aider les gouvernements
plus petits qui n'ont pas les moyens
pour aussi être avec nous et on le fait
avec beaucoup de coeur et beaucoup de
ressources et on doit continuer à le
faire mais avec l'aide de
david martinon qui représente la france
dans ce dans ce groupe par exemple on
est en train de chercher des moyens à
réformer le gac et l'améliorer et
l'amener au delà même de ce qu'on a fait
jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc c'est à eux
aogo vernement avec le leadership de
beaucoup de pays et l'âge appelle la
france à prendre ce rôle de leadership
même plus parce que la france est un
pays vraiment de du milieu comme même
que j'ai parlé à madame rousseff
elle m'a dit quel pays peut nous aider à
créer le milieu et jeudi la france et
c'est pour ça comme le président est
arrivé chez elle elle l'a invité à
participer à cette conférence parce que
la france peut vraiment donner du poids
au milieu est de trouver un modèle qui
est balancé qui ajoute ce qu'il faut je
voulais simplement ajouter quelque chose
à votre question il ya deux questions
vous m'avez bien demander la racine sy a
des racines ou d'autres racines
maintenant je comprends mieux votre
question je vous ne parliez pas des de
la racine kona avec les 13 vous parliez
d'une autre racines
c'est pour ça que vous avez vu ma
réaction un peu dur sur internet
allemand internet égyptien internet
si on commence à créer d'autres racines
on va perdre beaucoup d des bénéfices de
l'internet aujourd'hui des bénéfices
sociaux des bénéfices économiques et des
bénéfices politiques même l'importance
de garder une racine mais une racine du
monde
une racine que le monde à confidences
elle est vraiment sous une
responsabilité que le monde accepte cas
légitimité est très très importante et
j'espère que quand on parle d'internet
nationaux on parle d'eux
d'une nouvelle énergie pour créer des
idées des applications de nouvelles
choses sur l'internet mais pas de
fragmenter l'internet au long des des
bosses des frontières ça ça va être
vraiment une grande perte pour le monde
et comme quelqu'un qui vient d'une
petite minorité en egypte et que je
comprends et puis j'ai vécu au liban et
j'ai vu le liban un petit pays
ce cas c'est pendant les années 70 et 80
quand j'étais là-bas
j'espère j'espère qu'on mettra pas des
murs autour de cet internet une des
petites ressources du monde petit du
monde qui nous unit qui nous unit on
peut faire ce qu'on veut sur l'internet
mais dans l'internet l'unité très
importante et je crois elle est
importante pour moi pour vous pour nos
enfants pour l'humanité il faut la
garder
on croit que c'est un excellent mot de
conclusion je vais donc bien gardé d'y
ajouter quoi que ce soit je vais vous
redoublez vraiment nous remercient bon
d'avoir accepté cette cet échange qui a
été pour nous très intéressant et très
agréable puisque vous avez eu la
courtoisie de vous exprimer dans un
français parfait donc on était ravi de
vous entendre dans ces conditions merci
beaucoup j'espère que nous aurons
l'occasion d'échanger à nouveau ces
sujets en tout cas que l'occasion s'en
présentera excellent travail pour vous
d'une conférence à sao paulo
et puis nous serons attentifs évidemment
de notre rapport et au delà aux
évolutions vous avez annoncé
merci encore voilà vous ai donc pu
suivre cette audition de la mission
commune d'information sur le rôle de
l'union européenne dans la gouvernance
mondiale d'internet tout de suite la
suite de nos programmes sur public sénat